it's really great to be back in
Cleveland I can't can't believe that 25
years have gone by since I graduated
from this wonderful institution it's
just just phenomenal to think back how
much has changed and the trajectory has
been ever onward and upward and I can't
help but think part of that was because
I left loud but actually the one bone I
do want to pick with you Clevelanders as
has to do with with sports so for many
years we in San Diego rested very
comfortably knowing that there was a
city a very populous city that had gone
without a professional sports team
championship longer than San Diego and
that of course was Cleveland until
LeBron and the Cleveland can I say
LeBron anymore here is that okay anyway
until they Cavaliers won the NBA
championship and then Cleveland left the
title of longest suffering city without
a major-league championship team to San
Diego so we have not had a championship
team in San Diego thanks to you guys but
I always say you know the the you know
the easiest job in the world is San
Diego meteorologist but the hardest job
in the world is San Diego sportscaster
so you know it's we got to make up for
the wonderful lovely weather that we
have in some form or fashion so I'll
take it but it's nice to be here and a
lot is elapsed and as I said earlier
this afternoon in a cloak game at the
physics department a lot of you know
what I'm able to have achieved in my
life and the steps that I've had along
the way as my book details in a memoir
type fashion is in thanks in no small
part to this wonderful institution and I
just so tickled that I get to come back
here and speak to so many new friends
and older friends and and people I get
to call colleagues and give it give a
talk in the very classroom where my
physics career it was given birth to so
I want to talk a little bit about a very
very mysterious very interesting
character Alfred Nobel and how his life
and death actually intersected with my
life and hopefully not death for many
many more years and that is Alfred Nobel
and what he did with his eponymous prize
that the Nobel Prize which I claim is
the most
effective form of public relations
posthumously beyond the grave that has
ever been achieved and he did so
courtesy of another invention or another
association with with death and that was
the creation of dynamite so Alfred Nobel
famously created 355 patents and I point
out that 353 more than I've ever created
but I'm getting there slowly and one of
those in the most profitable by far was
dynamite
when dynamite was high tech in the 1860s
so much so that it was during the boom
in the westward expansion of the United
States the rail ray system etc that was
enabled in no small part by Alfred
Nobel's invention of dynamite which
itself was precipitated by many many
close encounters with death in the Nobel
family the most personal of which was
his younger brother Emil who had been
toying with nitroglycerin trying to make
a stabilized form of explosive that
could be used to be transported across
the world and possibly to America and
failed miserably and spectacularly a
fashion he ended up killing himself and
many people in the laboratory that the
Nobel family had in 1861 and three years
later Alfred continued to be obsessed
with this creation of an invention that
would allow its construction using
chemical inventions and that became
dynamite so he originally wanted to call
it Nobel safety powder so he was very
aware that you could make a lot of
difference by choosing a proper name and
he knew that people associated the Nobel
name with death so much so then in 1888
he had a surreal experience which is
that he was walking around the streets
of Paris and he saw a headline that
declared him Alfred Nobel to be the
merchant of death they single human
being in history had been responsible
for more death and carnage than any
other individual and it celebrated his
death and he could only take a little
bit of glee and knowing that he was
reading his own obituary so it couldn't
have been him right so the reports of
his demise were slightly exaggerated and
in fact it was his older brother Ludwig
Ludwig had died and in dying another
brush with death Alfred himself had a
revelation that is similar to the one
that Evan easer Scrooge had or George
Bailey
and it's a wonderful life which is that
he got a vision a revelation of what the
world really thought about him and how
he would be remembered after he was gone
for real so this was over exaggerated
but he knew this is the way the world so
he revised at that time that his legacy
would be for peace and for creation of
events and inventions that would better
the world and in doing so he endowed the
Nobel Prize and I claim the Nobel Prize
in the will that in doubt it are really
the most famous of all wills and
Testaments and in the second of the two
encounters in which I've lost the Nobel
Prize so I've had the opportunity to
lose it twice and two ways I'll explain
throughout the talk but in encountering
it and studying it in some depth during
the course of the events I described in
the book I came to see it as as very
much distorted from the no Bowl with le
vision that Alfred originally maintained
for it and I hope that convince people
that this this medal as good an effect
as it may have I mean we have buildings
dormitories that my friends lived in on
campus named after Nobel Prize winners
there's two of them right it was coach
Hall when I was here and michaelsen of
course we went to a restaurant today
michelson-morley as the lovely delicious
didn't exist when I was a student but
glad to see it made it there in San
Diego of all places you wouldn't
associate with the Nobel Prize we have a
street that called Nobel Drive it
intersects with another street called
Lebon drive what's Lebon backwards Nobel
it's written into the streets of San
Diego California why is that and I'll
explain some of the connections there
but it made me think about the impact
the outsized impact that the Nobel Prize
has that no other reward has not the
Oscars not the Latin Grammys not the
Emmys nothing compared to the Nobel
Prize and it really harkens back to an
earlier time in history when science was
done in a very different way than it's
done today and part of the book is to
agitate for changes in the way it's done
but certainly someone who would have won
the Nobel Prize had it been offered four
hundred years earlier was was a man by
the name of Galileo Galilei who invented
didn't invent he utilized the telescope
for the first time for astronomical
purposes and what he did with this
tellus
is turning into a lever and this lever
moved the entire earth figuratively it
displaced it from being the center of
the universe to a much more pedestrian
location in the you know middle suburbs
of the solar system so it made it
instead of being the most important
location in the universe it made it an
ordinary portion of the universe namely
the third Rock from the Sun as the as
the sitcom used to be called and in
doing so Galileo was able to transform
humanity's view of how the universe was
arranged he did so with her refracting
telescope and the telescope became a
tool to better inform and educate
Humanity on its proper place in its
regard for itself a dose of cosmic
humility that continued for centuries up
until a refractor by the name of bicep
started to ply the skies over the
southern hemisphere in the South Pole
I'll describe what happened in those
events directly connected the DNA of our
telescope is exactly the DNA of the
maestro in maestro's telescope Galileo's
telescope a couple of months about a
month ago at Williams College I got to
actually touch and take home no I didn't
get to take home a copy but it was it
was tempting
this is Galileo's Siderius nuncius which
is a publication I pointed out he
self-published without peer review in a
matter of weeks in 1610 after making
observations of the planet Jupiter and
the four stars that he claimed were in
orbit around it like vassals you know
surrounding a king or an entourage
surrounding you know Kanye West but in
any case these these stars seem to orbit
around Jupiter and he clearly identified
what is known to be the case today which
is a Jupiter is like a miniature solar
system of its own with every right to
call itself the center of its own
existence and that disproved the notion
that the earth was the center of the
solar system or the center of the solar
system and instead assured in was an
ocean of the universe as being centered
on the Sun or providing evidence for
that I spoke a little bit today about
what I consider Galileo is the biggest
blunder which involves this little tiny
collection of stars which you may be
familiar with from your car called
Subaru or the seventh
but it really illustrates the power that
the most humble substance in the
universe dust this pollutant that many
people believe is nothing but but to
treat us that gets in the way of all the
good stuff in the cosmos it actually
created an illusion that Galileo himself
the first astronomer to use a telescope
for astronomical purposes he too
stumbled upon this substance called dust
and this paragraph here he says what he
observed in the Milky Way was basically
conceived by him to be the entirety of
the cosmos comprised of stars and stars
alone and this was done in furtherance
to bolster the Copernican hypothesis in
other words he wants to say that not
only was the earth just an planet
amongst six other planets or five other
planets but so to where the Sun was the
Sun just a mere star amongst the
millions of Myriad's of stars that were
surrounding us of course we know now
that's not true and actually the
Pleiades or Subaru is actually
surrounded by dust and a nebula and in
fact Galileo's conjecture was was shown
to be wrong only in the last hundred
years when astronomers took observations
of the Pleiades nebula and show that it
was exactly identical to the composition
of the Starlight of the stars that
surrounded this this glowing this
glowing nebulosity as it was called and
actually we know now that these stars
are formed in these stellar nurseries
and not just stars the planets too in
fact the earth is nothing but a giant
ball of dust as I'll point out later
surrounding that's orbiting around the
earth reformed after being exploded out
from a star that existed perhaps five
billion years earlier than the Sun was
formed or 5 billion years ago so they
said the image that you should think of
your mind of how the solar system was
arranged the solar system being
effectively the entire universe in the
1600s was one that went from being Earth
centered heliocentric to heliocentric it
didn't come easily
when first Galileo postulated this idea
our evidence for Copernicus's idea which
Copernicus had in an
in the 1500s but this was the first
evidence provided by a refracting
telescope that moved the Earth from this
position of being the center of the
universe in a very stark and and unique
way that was essentially in arguable and
at first they brought Galileo a lot of
attention and and he needed attention
because he had at least two illegitimate
daughters there's a great book by Davis
elbow called Galileo's daughter and it
details how he went to great lengths to
be near his daughters who were you know
born out of out of Matt out of wedlock
which made them illegitimate and so they
had to become nuns and they were in
later life when he was in prison as I'll
explained he was allowed to live fairly
close to them and that was sort of a
nice bone that the Catholic Church threw
to him and at first you see Galileo here
with a dark beard so you can tell he's a
little bit younger he's probably about
my age
late 40s at this time in 1610 1611 he
wanted to make money he had a no small
amount of bills to pay and he had a
laboratory that he had a support in
nowadays you know we professors know
better graduate students they had their
assistants back then as well and this
this telescope he wasn't willing to
share the properties of how it worked
with anybody even Johannes Kepler who
had given a lot of data to Galileo that
led him at least on the path to
conjecture Copernicus was right so
Galileo would say when Copernicus say
I'm gonna be in the neighborhood I have
a cold I mean they're actually letters
written where Galileo says I've it's
gonna be cloudy when you're here next
month it's just but they were very
possessive of their data and we
scientists are not so far from that
nowadays we like to have and kind of be
possessive over quote-unquote our data
and sometimes that can have disastrous
consequences so here he is Galileo
showing the Venetian Senate and the the
powers of the telescope to potentially
gain advantage on their enemies who
would attempt otherwise to Surprise them
by coming over the horizon and the
Venetian Lagoon and attacking the the
state of Venice the sovereign state of
Venice and one hand Galileo profited
greatly as I pointed out today he became
the envy of professors everywhere
because the Venetian Senate
basically enforced upon the university
of padua that they had a higher Galileo
and permanently made him tenure okay
so instantaneously he goes from no
professorship tenured full professor and
they gave him twice as much startup
money as he requested so this is a dream
of all professors everywhere but it was
actually a dreadful thing for him
because it brought him within the sphere
of influence of the Vatican so at first
he made a lot of money he didn't build
telescopes he refused to divulge how he
made the telescope he kept it as a trade
secret like Apple is not going to tell
you know Google how they make their
iPhones they keep it as a trade secret
but he knew he could write books and
books he could roll off the printing
press himself and there are several
hundred copies of Siderius nuncius still
available and so if he actually went on
a miniature book tour within the state
of le
and it brought him no small shortage of
attention
there we see mrs. Kanye West signing
books John that's Kim Kardashian I think
but because he was now in Padua under
the influence of the Vatican the Vatican
sphere of influence not more than a few
hundred kilometers from Vatican City the
Pope eventually got wind of the
teachings of Galileo and ordered him to
stop teaching it which he didn't do and
months are years later about three
decades later after the Siderius nun see
as he published a dialogue full title is
the dialogue on to Chief world systems
in which he crafts the book as a
conversation between three different
people one representing him with a name
that roughly translates into the
brilliant one Subodh T and then he put
the words of Aristotle and Ptolemy in
the Pope's alter ego that he named
simply Co which means simpleton so that
wasn't so good that would be you know me
you know you're working here and sing
him the president Snyder you know
calling her simplicity oh that's not a
good way to get tenure you know but it
was worse for him so he actually had to
cower now you seen with the with a white
beard later on in life the last nine
years of his life he was sentenced the
house imprisonment of course he was a
couple miles away from his two daughters
in a convent but the view of the cosmos
that he ushered in was in contrast to
the Earth centered reality
the cosmos so Galileo realizes that it
did appear as if the earth is the center
of the solar system which was the
universe and so - does it appear the
earth is the center of many many
structures in the universe so we went
from thinking where the center of the of
the solar system to realizing we're just
a planet orbiting the center of the
solar system then the next stage of
cosmologists said well we're the center
of the galaxy the Milky Way galaxy is
centered on the earth or the Sun even
though the Sun is the center of our own
solar system the next step was is the
universe expanding and are we the center
of the universe and nowadays the
extension of these debates now revolves
around the question our are we the
center of the multiverse so it's not
that there's just another seven planets
besides the earth or that there's
another hundred billion stars in our
galaxy or that there's a hundred billion
galaxies in the observable universe it's
that there's an infinite possible
infinite number of other universes in
the multiverse and the extrapolation you
know if you're a mathematician
just keep extrapolating and so we're not
the center of any of those things so
we're not the center of the multiverse
either and the multiverse is where
things get really weird so hopefully
we'll chat a little bit about that the
view of the cosmos that we have now
extends all the way back to the earliest
light that a telescope or radio magnetic
detector can see called the cosmic
microwave background radiation that goes
back to about a half a million years
after the Big Bang that's the origin of
that light that's the oldest light now
half a million years out of three 13.8
billion years is pretty good but we
physicists are greedy we want to go back
to the very beginning of time itself and
to do that means you have to use a
different form of light or perhaps a
different form of radiation altogether
that's not electromagnetic in nature and
to do that colleagues and myself realize
we could do that using waves of gravity
instead of waves of light and gravity
goes through everything gravity from the
Earth from the moon goes all the way
through from you know San Diego to
Indonesia and creates high tides on both
opposite sides of the earth that means
gravity is going through the earth
gravity goes through everything it's the
weakest force but it has the longest
range effects so we realized with Kali
eggs and friends that you could go back
further than the first half million year
period in the universe's evolution for
perhaps a trillionth of a trillionth of
a trillionth of a second after the Big
Bang and that would be the so-called
period known as inflation which I
sometimes colloquially call the spark
that ignited the expansion of the
universe the spark that lit off the Big
Bang so astronomers discovered this in
of all places New Jersey so I'm a New
Yorker and so we get to make fun of so
I'll say you know this is the the best
thing that ever came out of New Jersey
besides John rule who went there for
graduate school and many others I'm sure
so we New Yorkers like to make fun of
New Jersey as I said but this telescope
was not looking to discover the Big Bang
it discovered it serendipitously by
accident looking to communicate with the
first radio transmitters placed in space
the Telstar satellite which was launched
just a few years after Sputnik this
communications link was plagued by a
background of excess noise that could
not be removed in any season any
direction any time of day and that
signal became known as the Cosmic
Microwave Background now if you go out
in any place in New Jersey and look up
at the sky this is what you see you see
this orange glow go now you know you
don't but this is what you'd see if you
had microwave eyes and then if you could
turn up the contrast and see if there
are any fluctuations in this background
signal this is what you'd see you'd see
this colorful tapestry that we call the
Cosmic Microwave Background and I saw
trippy and one of the projects John rule
worked on called boomerang first
discovered some of the dominant signal
in the modeling in this colorful pattern
and they make like stuffed animals out
of these out of this pattern it's quite
quite amazing and for my 40th birthday
my wife decorated a cake with this
pattern and she got the power spectrum
emailed on I was perfect now now my
friends at NASA animate this image and
show if you could follow one of these
fluctuations one of these hot spots or
cold spots in the microwave sky for
hundreds of millions and billions of
years you'd be pretty bored okay for the
first couple hundred million years
nothing would happen then eventually in
one of these colder spots the universe
would gravitate enough matter that stars
could form and then stars could form
into proto galaxies and then larger
galaxies could form like The Milk
and then eventually stars like our Sun
would form out of the ash heap of a
previous generation of stars called
population 2 and those stars would
provide the fuel for the earth and the
debris that surrounds us that we
discover in the form of dust and I'll
talk a lot about dust because I think it
is incredibly overlooked substance I
never thought I'd write a book about
dust and but but then I also yeah how
many of you hate dust jackets I used to
hate dust jackets fizzy read the book
falls out of it I actually didn't want
to have a dust jacket on this book my
publisher said no way you gotta have a
dust jacket on and I realized well my
books kind of about dust and then you
read a book by Stephen Hawking about
black holes and time warps and I love to
see a time warp cover you know on the
cover they don't make them so I figured
at least are gonna get some practical
use and my publisher says the next
edition will have actual cosmic dust
glued all over the cover so look forward
to that so you buy two copies no no
don't don't we fit so the main question
is how did you get to this image this
colorful modeled pattern if the universe
started out and it was predominantly
smooth well the that conjecture was sort
of addressed in the 1980s by Alan Guth
and other people and it was realized
that the universe had a start off with
tiny fluctuations and if it did if the
universe is pervaded by a quantum field
called the inflow time then that in
photon field would have tiny
fluctuations unavoidably quantum
mechanically and those fluctuations
would lead to the structures that we see
today so the logic is if the universe
started out pervaded by this tiny
quantum field these tiny seeds just like
a sequoia tree grows to be massive but
the seed of a sequoia is very many
Newton so from a tiny seed these huge
fluctuations these huge trees and
structures can grow and so too and the
cosmos so the cosmos could start off
with tiny fluctuations and they could be
amplified to eventually make over
densities and make planets and people
and and and performance halls like this
now what is that like in more human
terms so I always say this is this is a
this is a human embryonic stem cell
collection that's basically an embryo a
thousand seconds after conception I
won't make the joke about the Big Bang
here but but imagine you trying to
figure out who this belongs to
or perhaps observing the person today
invert their their visit today and say
what do they look like when they were in
embryo a thousand seconds after
conception could you do such a thing
well since you can't guess who this
person is yet I've added some
distinguishing features and of course
you can all guess this person is my
children's favorite astronomer of all
time Neil deGrasse Tyson you don't know
how painful that is people you know kids
worshiped Neil deGrasse Tyson so here
Neil is he actually just turned 60 years
old which is roughly two billion seconds
old so if you convert your age to
seconds you can feel really old if you
like try to get into a bar doing that
and it won't be successful but it'll be
clearly impossible to try to do this
right if you were trying to look at
someone who's two billion seconds old
wonder what they look like at after a
thousand seconds of life then you'd be
kind of considered crackpot if you try
to get a funding grant from the NIH to
do that but instead we think we can do
much more than that
using a picture of the CMB in the Cosmic
Microwave Background at an age of 1/2 a
million years extrapolate back forty
four orders of magnitude more in time we
believe we can do that using what's
called gravitational radiation or
gravitational waves similar in spirit to
the gravitational waves detected by LIGO
in 2015 and these gravitational waves if
present if inflation took place would
shake up the cosmic background radiation
and cause it to have a particular type
of polarization called b-mode
polarization not important why we call
it that but nevertheless this pattern
could be detectable we realized back in
2001 and I pitched this idea to my
postdoc advisor colleague late colleague
of John and myself named Andrew Lang at
Caltech and he jumped at the idea I
thought he was gonna fire me it would
have been my second time being
terminated within about a year but
you'll you'll read about that story in
my book but the idea to do this to go
after the signal was one that Galileo
would immediately recognize it's a
refracting telescope it just refract
microwaves instead of optical visible
light but Galileo first of all knew a
lot about thermometry and cold
temperatures he complained about the
coldness of the temperature of Padua in
January he built the Galilean
thermometer he'd probably seen these
with little jars of alcohol and oil that
float to different heights when their
temperatures change but this telescope
is a refracting telescope that
microwaves using lenses not of glass but
of high density polyethylene very simple
material used in milk jugs that you see
a picture of there and you can tell that
you can see through such lens made of
this material because if you've ever
gone to go get the milk out of the
refrigerator you can actually feel it's
cold before you touch it and that means
you're feeling heat infrared radiation
which is invisible so invisible light
goes through this high-density
polyethylene material that milk jugs are
made about it and so we use that
property and the fact that they refract
and bend microwaves to focus microwaves
from the Big Bang onto our detectors
that was it
detectors are much more advanced than
Galilei or not much more advanced in
Galileo's eyeball much less advanced
than a human retina but nevertheless
they have far fewer pixels but they work
using superconductivity and the
temperature of a super conductivity in a
superconductor and it's resistance are
intimately related so when a little bit
of energy falls into a superconductor it
can become a non superconductor a
conductor a resistor and doing that
transition and playing some very clever
games that way Coen Co built by Jamie
Bach and Andrew Lang and others at
Caltech these devices can be exquisite
detectors of heat from the Big Bang they
can detect the most minut signals
emanating from this purported epoch of
inflation and so he built this telescope
we and we put it not on a rickety wooden
and led mount as Galileo was using there
we put on this big massive 10,000 pound
mount and spontaneously acquired a
twitter account and this telescope does
everything that Galileo's did in other
words you can point it left and right up
and down but you could also spin it
about the central axis of the telescope
that was very important for looking for
what we're trying to attempt to find
it's called polarization and to do that
you need to spin the telescope around so
this massive telescope thousands of
pounds can rotate and it can spin and
can locate itself and stop literally
within a human hairs breath and it's
been operating almost non-stop for the
last ten years at the South Pole now why
do we go to the South Pole well there's
the South Pole it's not the bottom of
the world or the top of the world
depending on your perspective it's
always the part of the world on a globe
that they put the stick that holds up
the
yes it always gets literally the short
end of the stick but actually it's one
of the most beautiful places to go if
you get there nowadays it wasn't always
such a great place to visit as these
pictures depict so 107 years ago 107
years ago next and next month basically
expeditions came and reached the South
Pole for the very first time and there
are two expeditions competing at the
same time very much reminiscent of the
space race to reach the moon or a race
to get there first to discover something
for the first time and win a Nobel Prize
I know as many parallels between the two
and actually these two teams were
fighting and they were aware of each
other's progress and they were trying to
scoop each other to reach the South Pole
first now you see there were two
different technological approaches here
so the upper team is the team led by
Amundsen a Norwegian explorer who tried
to get to the North Pole first and was
beaten and he immediately turned around
said his men ships and dogs importantly
dogs down to the southern hemisphere to
reach the South Pole first 1910 1911 the
British used a much more sophisticated
form of transportation called the
graduate student no no they're not
graduates invasor
these are far more value no no these are
these whereas other men that were on the
expedition now why did they choose to do
this well they were proper British
gentlemen and British gentlemen knew
that their Norwegians were gonna eat the
dogs in fact they did as soon as they
got to the South Pole they had a nice
dinner of deep-fried dog or whatever
they did roast dog and then to get home
they're actually able to ski downhill
it's about 8,000 9,000 feet above sea
level when you get to the South Pole
so skiing up it's the hard part skiing
down is easy there's actually some wind
event that you get a little push from
coming back down to where they left from
Antarctica
now when the British team you can see as
Jean can verify bit having been to South
Pole when you get to the South Pole it's
basically like going out into the middle
of Lake Erie freezing it's solid outside
of land side completely and you see
nothing but flatness whiteness and waves
of frozen snow so you can see stuff
that's really far away so for days they
saw something stay
hanging up out of the ground now they
didn't know you know there's no
Instagram no they didn't know that
they'd been beaten so they got to the
South Pole and they saw our Norwegian
flag sticking up allograph so what do
they do it kind of reminds me of like my
little brothers when I would like you
know when I when I would get a high
score and Tetris or whatever you know
back then you know they would
immediately try to see that oh I cheated
or did something wrong so the the
British went and they surveyed the site
they wanted to see oh maybe they're off
by 10 feet and maybe we can claim we got
to the south but they found out they
actually were accurate and as far as
they could tell that they had been
beaten to the South Pole and and Scott
famously declared Great God this is an
awful place and all the more so for
having reached it without the benefit of
priority meaning that it was almost like
inconsequential to be the second person
to make an achievement like this you
know many of the experiments we did I
was talking to Professor Chopin or many
of the experiments that you had us do
were basically Nobel Prize winning and
we did the michelson-morley experiment
in one of our labs now that won a Nobel
Prize in 1907 so it's amazing how
quickly something goes from Nobel nobody
can do it
Nobel prize-worthy to we're doing it in
the lab sometimes a few years after it
was discovered and so so - with the
South Pole and so - with the moon and I
like to equate this discovery so
tomorrow a new movie called first man
comes out there's been a lot of
controversy about that movie because
they don't show the American flag for
summer I haven't seen the movie I want
to see it it looks really cool but
imagine yourself back in 1969 when when
astronauts landed on the moon for the
first time and Neil Armstrong gets out
and he's not the first man he's the
second man and he puts the flag oh my
god there's a Russian Soviet flag there
imagine how pio deed be right I mean
this would be devastating that he could
land and be second right so that's how
it felt for them back then and nowadays
you know all these guys died ok sorry
Lee they all died because they made a
miscalculation they took extra people
because he was actually trying to be
more inclusive and bring more men than
he needed which meant they act ate more
food they used up their calories quicker
and they were more susceptible to
injuries just having more people there
and some of them got frostbite and
slowed down the whole team they ended up
all dying within about 7 miles of
last supply cache of food and fuel that
would have kept them alive so a
difference of three weeks and the change
in weather in a mere three weeks at the
South Pole they got there in January I
haven't got there in December that made
a difference being life and death
their bodies weren't discovered for for
several years afterwards so it's still
not the safest place to go to as this
video very grainy that I shot on my last
expedition shows somebody my
five-year-old always wants me to bring
back a penguin when I'm there so I
figured maybe they don't like people you
know maybe penguins they just don't like
people maybe their penguin people
they're not people people so I took
another video just to give the benefit
of the doubt and this is what I saw so
they're really they're are not the
nicest creatures so you know we went out
to dinner earlier tonight you know and I
was trying to figure out do I want do I
want chicken or fish well choose penguin
it's kind of like the perfect
combination now when you go there
nowadays it's so much easier you get all
your clothing needs all your food needs
all your traffic transportation needs
all taken care of courtesy of the US
government so you go down there you go
to and collect all of your clothing that
you're gonna need if you're there
depending on how long you're there if
you're there for a whole year
they're just so called winterover you
get to bring an extra bag well that's
pretty nice of clothing and you get a
boarding pass and they sniff you for
certain substances though they don't
want brought down there to the South
Pole and you get on a plane and
hopefully you don't see this although I
saw this the first couple of times they
went down to the South Pole and you can
see this is a c-130 cargo plane it's the
workhorse of the US Air Force and this
one has been sold to the New Zealand
government and the New Zealanders don't
have many enemies I figured out because
this is about 10% of their entire Air
Force you're looking at it and then you
can barely see it underneath the the
fuel tank that looks like a giant bomb
but there's a picture of their logo and
the United States Air Force my
stepfather was in the Air Force and you
used to regale me their logo is the
screaming eagle the Falcon the day
talons of Raptors of death the what's
the logo of the of the New Zealand Air
Force the kiwi bird a flightless bird
that's what you get when you have no
enemies they're like the Switzerland of
the southern hemisphere anyway you get
your clothes and you get on your private
limo to the South Pole and the very
front you can see first class and
immediately next to a business class and
then they comment no it's all one class
there's almost no windows on the plane
you can see here so good luck getting a
window there is one non flushable toilet
called the honeypot and for four reasons
I won't get into and and you get a bag
of mystery meat of some form or another
to sustain you but it's only for eleven
and a half hours so that's not so bad
yeah you can do anything for eleven
hours eventually you land in McMurdo and
finally you get to the South Pole maybe
a couple of days later and you see your
experiment the one you've been pitching
trying to get funding for battling with
colleagues who say you're an idiot
trying to build this experiment no one's
ever gonna believe you can never do it
every bit and you finally get to see
this creation at the South Pole it's
really you know for a kid who had a
telescope since age 12 it was really
just an incredibly proud moment for me
to see the telescope located in the
building we had at the South Pole of
course that was only after getting my
luggage at the beautiful passenger
terminal at the South Pole on the left
you see the president's Club the
Admirals Club is in the middle
ambassador Circle isn't now there's none
of that that's all you get and remember
this is what Scott had a face all right
so you called an awful place nowadays
it's much nicer but this is this is them
to scale so remember if you went out
into Lake Erie and he froze it flash
froze it and there was any wind
whatsoever there be waves of snow that
froze into place there's a name Eskimo
name our Inuit name is called assessed
roogie you know they have names for
millions of types of snow and this means
wave of frozen snow and underneath these
waves of frozen snow are caverns of ice
that you can collapse and get sucked
into and die and they had a ski over it
but as I said it was only for 700
nautical miles up 10,000 feet nearly
above sea level it's just astonishing
that they did this and they took this
selfie the guy in the lower left is
holding a string to take this selfie and
immediately upload to the cloud now when
I got there I thought it was awesome I
also took a picture and I said this is
an awesome place not an awful place this
is my accommodations when I was there
it's actually as wide as my arms held
outstretched which is still smaller by a
little bit than a California state
prison cell the walls are made of
cubical material so you can hear your
neighbors sleep apnoea quite loudly and
clearly but it's pretty nice the the
main downside is that it's light 24
hours a day when I'm there it's during
the Austral summer so the Sun is up 24
hours a day just makes a circle above
your head it drives you mad when you get
up at 3:00 in the morning your body
doesn't know you've to go to the
bathroom and then you step out in the
light and you're just blinded by this
incredibly bright brilliantly bright
light reflecting off this ice shelf that
extends hundreds of miles in all
directions so here I am inside my dorm
and you can see the dome there is a dome
that used to be there in the back and
then here's the bicep to the reason I
was there this is where the bicep
observatory is it's not that cone is not
a collector of light that's actually
meant to keep the hot radiation from the
surrounding cold frozen polar plateau
it's still even though it's so cold it's
actually much much brighter than the
signals we're trying to see the reason
we go down to the South Pole is shown in
this image so if you go out I heard
yesterday was a nice day I don't know
why I couldn't arrange for a nice day
today but anyway it actually brings me
back to most of the way I remember the
weather being 25 years ago but if you
went out yesterday and you looked about
this far above the horizon you would see
a sky that's almost kind of maybe bluish
white but mostly white but at the South
Pole when you do that you get this inky
blackness of the sky in fact when you
look straight up it's almost like
looking into space and that's why we go
there there's very little water vapor in
the south polar atmosphere why is water
vapor bad well your microwave oven works
by absorbing microwave energy from a
generator inside the inside of the oven
and that generator generates microwave
energy that vibrates and agitates water
molecules so much that they start to
boil which is why you can put water in a
ceramic cup put it in for 10 minutes I
don't know advertise doing this out
there but you can put it in for many
many minutes the water will become
superheated but you could still touch
the ceramic because the ceramic has no
water in it so water absorbs microwaves
we don't want a water molecule a
kilometer or 10 kilometers above the
telescope to absorb this Photon
memory this photos been traveling for
13.8 two billion years we don't want the
last millisecond of its life to get
intercepted by a water molecule so you
want to go somewhere that's very dry
what's the driest place in the world
well it's not in the world it's in space
but a space experiment we realise would
cost a hundred times more than building
bicep at the South Pole so we decided to
do it there that's the building it's in
the second-most important building at
the South Pole okay now remember we're
looking for this twisting pattern this
very twisting swirling pattern of
microwaves that would be indicative of
gravitational waves which themselves
would be indicative of inflation causing
the ignition of the Big Bang if you like
speaking very loosely and we claim we
saw it on January 17 2014
st. Patrick's Day we announced to the
whole world that we had detected this
pattern called b-mode polarization which
meant effectively as we claimed a
detection of the earliest physical epoch
in the history of the universe the
inflationary epoch and we got a lot of
attention for it many people might
recognize there was a video produced by
Stanford University a few weeks before
the announcement and it showed one of
the men who's considered the pioneer a
pioneer of the inflationary theory
Andrei Linde and his wife Renata Kailash
at Stanford University faculty
celebrating with one of our colleagues
channeling Kuo and this video got two
million views within an hour so all
around the world people were tuning in
to see what this announcement was all
about we had claimed we had witnessed a
discovery that was clearly as John said
no bail worthy and people were talking
about it instantaneously but also that
we had witnessed the the earliest
evidence in the history of the universe
that could ever be gathered so as big if
not bigger than any discovery according
to many people that had ever been made
so it's quite astonishing there was a
press conference that we had at Harvard
there were Nobel laureates in the
audience of that press conference in
front of presumed to be future Nobel
laureates and it made headlines all
around the world
I'm sure the Plain Dealer covered it as
well it made the front page of the of
the newspaper of record the one that
prints then all the news that's fit to
print the San Diego union-tribune
of course there I am on the front cover
looking up at a bunch of zeros that show
how far back in seconds we had seen back
to the beginning of time and I like the
headline in the bottom from the from The
Economist because it kinda sounds like
there's just some dude and he's looking
at but my favorite headline of all was
in the true scientific journal of record
of course we all know what it is the
onion the onion convened a panel of
expert physicists including Michio Kaku
and rhythm and blues R&B singers like
Aretha Franklin late great Aretha
Franklin Sonny Robinson Smokey Robinson
rather and Diana Ross and they debated
the meaning of forever and the caption
underneath it says panelists discuss
whether it is theoretically possible to
give you my heart forever when the
bottom one says we can observe long-term
phenomena like the CMB primordial b-mode
polarization they really said this and
the love between india.arie and her man
all of which seemed to have existed
since the universe's infancy now Nobel
gold for us alas was not to be and we
quickly came under criticism from many
groups actually within hours people were
criticizing a result saying we had seen
another type of signal that was
unintentionally the masquerading as a
signal we were seeking and that was
called synchrotron radiation radiation
from Radio galaxy radio pollution
spinning dust grains etc and they
claimed that we had seen actually
galactic dust contamination at low
frequencies from from radio sources we
quickly sprang into action and we
decided that that claim was without
merit and we actually disproved it
within a couple of weeks
team members did and so we rested
comfortably and I was reminded of this
quote by by Winston Churchill who said
there's nothing in life as satisfying as
being shot at without result so
literally we had dodged a bullet and we
felt even more confident that we were
bound for this history book the glory of
Nobel gold and other the thrill of being
correctly validated with this discovery
later it was discovered that actually we
had seen
the imprint of dust and that this dust
signal had masqueraded not at low
frequencies but at the exact frequencies
we were measuring and it only came about
thanks to a collaboration with a
competitor called a satellite called the
Planck satellite and these two teams our
team and their team worked together to
figure out that we had actually seen
very accurately a signal from this very
prosaic substance called dust when the
dust itself is caused from the same star
that exploded to give life and give
material to our solar system the nebula
that produced our planet was produced
and also amounts of dust and throughout
our galaxy as well so we now know that
the cosmos is not centered on us but
it's also not a very clean place as I
say you know those of us from Southern
California can attest it's a very smoggy
place it's filled with dust pollutants
that are about a few hundred microns
long that can become magnetized like
microscopic meteorites and just like a
meteorite has magnetic property so - -
these tiny grains of dust they get
aligned in the Milky Way's magnetic
field and exactly mimicking an impostor
signal of what we were trying to see so
our discovery literally went down to
dust but I don't want people to think
that dust is all bad because dust is us
sorry I wax poetically in the book and I
price self-indulgent ly have a poem but
it's not as good as Carl Sagan's
treatise on dust where he said that the
earth is basically a giant ball of dust
so this this picture is a selfie of the
earth taken by the Voyager satellite in
1990 and Valentine's Day 1990 they
commanded Voyager to turn around and
take a selfie of the earth and so if
you're older if you were born after
February 14 1990 you're in this picture
in some form or another a single pixel
captured the entire planet and it was
bathed in light from the Sun and he
poetically describes it as that dot is
here is home is us every saint and
sinner in the history of our species
lived there on a mote of dust suspended
on a sunbeam it's pretty beautiful it
really means that the dust is us the
dust is our planet our planet is a giant
ball of dust and dust as ubiquitous that
only causes the need for dust jackets
but it actually allows us to exist so it
does
blew away you know our signal and blew
away the Nobel Prize for many of us but
all was not lost because just a matter
of weeks later after losing this closest
encounter that I'm likely ever to get
with the Nobel Prize I came to my office
exactly three years ago today and I came
into my office and I found this document
waiting for me and it said Professor
Brian Keating we on behalf of the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences we as
members of the Nobel Committee on
physics have the honor of inviting you
to submit a proposal for the award of
Nobel Prize in Physics in 2016 and it
goes on to say this now by the way
please please I implore you everyone
watching on the Internet it says
strictly confidential don't tell anyone
I could get in a lot of trouble no I put
it in the book so anyway that I think
they're mad at me but I so far I've
survived the instructions that were
given to me to make an invitation to
nominate somebody set me on a path of
Inquisition as to the origins of the
Nobel Prize and what was intended by the
namesake creator of the Nobel Prize
Alfred Nobel and I think it's pretty
interesting when you look at it how far
it deviated and that's what I'm going to
get into but to give you a sense of how
humiliating quite frankly it was to do
this imagine so imagine you guys so
there are some of my brothers Michael
Phi Kappa theta is out there in the
audience
imagine you didn't get accepted the case
and it was your dream school like mine
but the admissions committee you know
Dean Taylor and somebody else sends you
a letter the president Snyder and it
says you know dear sir/madam we regret
to inform you're not getting accepted to
Case Western but could you tell us
somebody who deserves to be accepted to
gaze west that's the way it felt this
was my Nobel Prize darn it and to be
asked to nominate somebody for it in
place of myself and it actually says
there's a special piece of the
invitation I'm sure here it says you may
not nominate yourself so that was great
you know even my ego is not that big but
I went back and and knowing fluent
Swedish as I do I mean we all do here we
all learn at freshman year here right
okay I looked at Alfred Nobel's will and
it's surprising this thing endowed
billions of dollars of prizes and
attention it's written by hand and what
like to be a napkin it was written in
1895 seven years after his brothers
misattributed a [ __ ] you remember they
had already declared him dead once
before he sprang into action took him
seven years but he wrote that his will
by hand he wrote it down a year before
he died and we're in a synagogue so I
can't help but but quote from the Talmud
the Talmud rabbi thar fond says repent
one day before you die meaning you don't
know when you're gonna die right so you
should always be in this state so he
died almost exactly a year to the day
after writing down this well so it was
very fortuitous for him and so I I don't
speak Swedish but I went through it and
and I and they have a translation on the
Nobel Prize website and it says in the
second sentence I'll tell you what the
first sentence says a very egregious
sentence that I'll explain later but the
second sentence says the whole of my
estate shall be distributed annually in
the form of prizes to those who during
the preceding year shall have conferred
the greatest benefit to mankind a
portion as follows one part of the
person the person in the singular who
shall have made the most important
discovery invention and physics okay so
there are three clauses a single person
who made the greatest beneficial
discovery in the preceding year and this
started tweaked my curiosity because I I
went back to the letter I received and I
read lined it and it says worked on long
ago maybe selecting the award only on
the supposition that its significance
had been until recently not been fully
appreciated and then they also the
underlined they put in parentheses
canidates plural and they don't mention
anything about the beneficence conferred
by the discovery so the only three
things that Alfred Nobel wanted were
either very significantly or completely
omitted in the instruction letter that I
was asked to provide I did more research
I asked the question has anyone ever won
a Nobel Prize the year after discovery
and that had a great benefit to mankind
and was a single person and what I found
was quite interesting so there are three
there are three different inventions or
discoveries all made during the Nobel
Prize epoch all eligible for Nobel
Prizes in other words numbered one two
and three I'm going to ask for a vote
show of hands so number one is the RNA
molecule the precursor to life
self who thinks number one won the Nobel
Prize at some point in the last hundred
and seventeen years okay who thinks the
periodic table Mendel leaves creation
was eligible for the Nobel Prize for
many years has element number 102 named
anybody know 102 nobelium so that
element named after Alfred Nobel who
thinks number two P R temple won the
Nobel Prize okay a couple brothers over
there who thinks the lighthouse won the
Nobel Prize and who does not like to
raise their hand get him up high and
let's go of course it's the lighthouse I
got here by lighthouse I mean who didn't
you know I John drove us here he was
consulting with the lighthouse he
doesn't use Siri or you know GPS he was
the lighthouse to get everybody know
Gustov delenn swede by the way if you
want to win a nobel prize be born in
sweden because you have a higher chance
per capita he wanted for invention of
automatic regulators for regulating
lighthouses and buoys very important one
for the ages of course he wanted that a
year after its invention he's a single
person perfectly in a court of that
alfred nobel wanted maybe not super
useful to this very day but nevertheless
it's not the only controversy that's
beset the nobel prize here's another
couple of examples i won't comment on
them but they've been a lot of
controversy associated with the to
denote with two Nobel Peace Prizes at
least and then Bob Dylan didn't even
show up to get his Nobel Prize in
Literature two years ago nobody show is
going to show up this year on Alfred
Nobel's death date the prizes are given
out December 10th Alfred Nobel's
anniversary of his death not his
birthday kind of weird creepy little
creepy but but but Bob Dylan didn't even
show up this year no one will show up
because they canceled the Nobel Prize in
Literature this year because of a sex
scandal allegedly perpetrated by the
husband of the secretary of the Swedish
Academy of literature that selects a
Nobel Prize in Literature in other words
her husband was having affairs with
women or maybe trying to incur favored
to win Nobel prizes in literature for
themselves and divulge information about
the Nobel Committee and as she took the
fall for it many people think that
that's egregious oversight and they may
not give it away next year either
there's an investigations unit that
normally investigates the Swedish mafia
if they're investigating the
finances of literature prize so there's
been a lot and of course our dear leader
is being in the running for the Nobel
Prize not this year he didn't win it
this year but he's he's been nominated
for next year's Nobel Prize and anybody
can nominate people for the Peace Prize
so keep that in mind you know I can even
nominate myself so what was the first
sentence I said showed you the second
sentence and here's the first sentence
it says I Alfred Nobel do hereby declare
after mature deliberation declare the
following to be my last will and
testament to my nephew's slam war and
ludwig Nobel I would decrease the sum of
two hundred thousand crowns and to my
niece Mina one hundred thousand crowns
so what do you notice the girl gets half
as much as the guy and until recently
until last week the number of Nobel
Prize winning women in physics work
could fit on this slide these are the
only two women that won the Nobel Prize
in Physics until last week thank
goodness Marie Curie and she at least
who only won it after many many decades
and much arduous struggle Marie Curie's
husband Pierre refused to accept the
Nobel Prize unless she wanted they
didn't want to give it to her in 1903
but they were he refused to accept it
unless she did it was awarded Maria get
Bart mayor UC San Diego my home
institution won the Nobel Prize 1963 and
when she wanted her son told me the
headline in the newspaper the newspaper
record said San Diego housewife wins
Nobel Prize and for the next 54 years no
woman had won a Nobel Prize and so I
used to say yeah there's many women on
the back of the Nobel Prize as have won
the Nobel Prize so there are two women
on the back Mother Nature and the genius
of science two goddesses and then
there's a guy in the front and this is
called the Bechdel test I'm told so when
there's two women and one guy they're
always talking about a guy but thank
goodness last week Donald Donna
Strickland won it and of course she
wanted for work done decades ago and her
advisor shared it with her Arthur Ashe
c't he's 96 years old many people
thought you know he was aggrieved by not
winning at decades earlier when it was
awarded for inventions and discoveries
related to optical tweezers but anyway I
thought it was a great change to the
Nobel Prize but still endure
the symbol of all most exalted
idolatrous nature and I witnessed this
firsthand so on May 11th last year
Duncan Hall Dane who had been a
professor at UC San Diego in the 90s he
did work on topological states of matter
that later resulted in the 2016 Nobel
Prize the year that I was nominated
winners for the Nobel Prize I did not
nominate him don't tell him he'll be mad
but no he won't be mad he came back on
May 11th and gave us gave a cloak in and
he brought with him his Nobel Prize
he's trying ever leave home without it
it's like American Express and he
brought it with him and you can't even
see it one of the students is holding it
and it's glowing with this brilliant
intensity of a thousand suns and
professors came up to it and we're
touching it and taking pictures and
kissing in licking it and all crazy
stuff with it and I realize it's kind of
like again we're in a synagogue so I'm
gonna get a little biblical here so I
always thought well you know the story
the golden calf was kind of too strange
to believe so the Israelites leave Egypt
and God has these huge plagues
devastates Egypt 40 days later they make
a cast golden statue of a cloth the
so-called golden calf I said this is
totally irrational no one who'd ever
actually witnessed the miracles of Egypt
being visited on the on the Egyptians
would ever fall victim to making a calf
out of gold and worshipping him
themselves that's ridiculous but the
most secular maybe the most intelligent
rational people in humanity at least
people tell me so or physicists and yet
even physicists couldn't resist coming
up and touching this gilded graven image
with a picture of Alfred Nobel on it
that you have to bow down to on his
death day to accept it repulsed me I
actually felt physically sick that
colleagues of mine would stoop so low as
to worship an idol of gold that they had
made themselves it was revolting it was
disgusting
this was on the day I submitted the
manuscript for this book
I've been railing against and even I
succumb to its lustrous power it shows
you that we're not so far removed from
these you know 30th century BCE idol
worshipers of yore so it's a long
tradition now he's a wonderful man I
really enjoy him but but this is not
only confined to the Nobel Prize you may
have heard that just recently in August
the Fields Medal which is called as you
see in this article it's often referred
to as a Nobel Prize for mathematics
there is no Nobel Prize for mathematics
nobody knows why some say it's because
Alfred Nobel's wife was having an affair
and had children with a mathematician
which is false and multiple accounts he
never married had no children and this
the woman was not related to him in any
way this award then the Fields Medal is
sort of called that and minutes after it
was given this past year it was stolen
why would you steal thing else it's
worth 15,000 Canadian ok that's pretty
good but but besides that it's to get a
piece it's to get this posterity it's to
get this lustrous representation of the
pinnacle of human mind but why isn't the
accomplishment the sign I mean the
person who stole it's probably not going
through the derivations that this
gentleman went through to derive that
will actually won him the Fields Medal
it's because people want to attach
themselves to a physical entity that's a
craving that many people have including
myself as a younger person and despite
all the tragic implications for the the
one who had his Fields Medal stolen it
actually gave me a great idea for my
next book title of course it will be
stealing the Fields Medal okay that's
good success with losing another now the
next books coming out soon I want to
close with some suggestions for the
future and I'll take some questions and
leave time for thunderous applause but I
do want to say this quote from Ghandi
really sums up my relationship with
idols of gold idols of dust and
essentially the humility that we need to
have when we conduct ourselves a
scientist and Gandhi said that the
seeker after truth should be humbler
than the dust because dust is crushed
upon by human feet but a human being
should see himself as vulnerable to
being crushed by dust
only then and not until then will he
have a glimpse of truth this is his book
story of my experiments with truth
Gandhi nominated for the Nobel Prize 13
times never won it
Hitler was nominated once of despicable
memory and I do want to just point out
that yeah he never won at Gandhi never
wanted even though he contributed such
tremendous benefits to the world and
avoiding perhaps would have been one of
the bloodiest conflicts in history so on
the science side I've come to not regard
the Nobel Prizes that be-all and end-all
of my career but instead working with
colleagues 244 of them not just one of
them
working on a project called the Symons
Observatory which is a very ambitious
project as John pointed out I spoke
about earlier and there's information on
the web about it
it's a massive telescope that's gonna be
observing the Sun of the southern
hemisphere looking for the echoes of
creation and looking for dust to get rid
of dust you must think like dust and you
must outsmart the dust which is harder
than it sounds
so the final sentence of Alfred Nobel's
will has always intrigued me
he suffered from a terrifying fear that
he would be buried alive and it's
actually a psychological condition
that's called tappa phobia the fear of
being buried alive and his final
sentence of the will says finally it's
my express wish that following my death
my veins shall be cut open and when this
has been done and competent doctors have
confirmed clear signs of my death by the
way if his veins are cut off I mean he's
gonna be dead but if you really want to
be dead because look at that I might
remain shall be cremated in a so-called
crematorium so he's really dead this guy
who wanted to be dead dead he actually
invented a series of tubes that could
transport coffins beneath the streets of
Stockholm that would have bells in them
that could be wrong if people were still
alive there but I actually don't know if
they actually followed through with his
wishes because they violated so many
other things in his win as well I wonder
if they actually did this but but I
thought it was important to open the
veins on the Nobel Prize process and so
we created a website called losing the
Nobel Prize that org where you can vote
on changes or people you think should
win the Nobel Prize so down there you
see Jocelyn Bell is received it's kind
like moveon.org for super nerds like me
and we voted on people that should
deserve the Nobel Prize and actually
Jocelyn Bell was one of the top vote
getters and she just
on the $3,000,000 breakthrough prize for
her discovery of pulsars that went
awarded a nobel prize to her male PhD
advisor in 1974 so hopefully we can
rectify that situation just reminds you
last day to have registered a vote so to
vote for the Nobel Prize and vote in
Ohio as well and I'll leave time for
questions thank you very much
[Applause]
you